The Witcher 3 was one of the biggest
games of 2015 and we'll see more of the
northern kingdoms when the blood and
wine expansion releases in the coming
months but if you want to literally get
your hands on garel Dark Horse deluxe
has you covered they've got a lineup of
which your figurines coming this year
we've only seen Gerald so far but
figures for Tris Jennifer Siri and
eridan are also planned each custom
painted collectible will cost you thirty
bucks CD projekt red's woof all yucky
said we are truly excited to bring the
witcher 3 characters to life Wild Hunt
fans requested figures of garel serie en
and other collectibles multiple times
and now thanks to this cooperation we're
finally able to fulfill these requests
without putting an arm and a leg on the
price tag I truly hope what your fans
notice all the love and the excellent
craftsmanship put into creating them
Dark Horse deluxe is also working on
jewelry replicas barware and other
Witcher 3 collectibles if they release
more images you'll certainly see them on
gamespot and for more on CD projects
next game you're already in the right
place